the equation is easy energy affects
everyone from our homes to businesses to
vital services across the country and
now with an unprecedented jump in prices
every sector of life will feel a cash
crunch
finances have already been slipping at
this lubricant factory in salford the
new gas prices will take another chunk
out of their profits our costs are going
up it's a concern
to make sure that we're competitive in
the marketplace and so far we've eaten
into it it's eaten into our margin and
maybe in the spring the prices might be
down if they're not
then the product that we're going to
have to pass the prices through to the
consumer
natalie spends most of her time helping
others but time is money and with higher
bills money becomes really tight it's
devastating absolutely devastating i've
got
grandchildren that need porridge in the
morning that takes at least 15 minutes
the heating has to be on for them to
come shower has to be on for them to
wash
that's a hundred pound more every
quarter i can't have dough just don't
have it
at the trinity house community centre in
rush home cash is already strapped it
takes a lot to heat this old victorian
building it's now going to take even
more so we want to be welcoming we want
people to feel comfortable when they
walk through the door we don't want them
shivering
and it might come to that we might have
to say look
we can't let out the building in the
evenings anymore we can't have youth
groups because the heating's got to go
down
so it could lead to services ending
britain faces a bleak winter businesses
on the brink of collapse millions of
homes facing no heating and whilst the
regulator says help is available as the
numbers go up it's clear for many life
gets tougher in zaman rashid sky news
manchester